all right joining me now is tennessee
senator bill hagerty who serves on the
senate foreign relations committee
senator um you heard my conversation
earlier with peter ducey
we're still buying an enormous amount of
energy
from russia
russia is attacking ukraine
and now congress is going to be asked to
spend
6.4 billion dollars that we're going to
have to br print or borrow
to send to ukraine so we're we're kind
of paying every which way in this
situation your reaction tonight indeed
and
now my reaction is very simple laura
your discussion with peter underscores
it but we're actually funding
the war machine that putin is using and
unleashing on ukraine right now you
think about the short-sighted policies
these green policies that the biden
administration began at the outset of
their administration to wage war in the
oil and gas industry here have driven
energy prices up around the globe that
windfall has come straight to vladimir
putin and here we are buying his energy
and continuing to fund these activities
the sanctions are going to take a long
time to work now because putin has built
up a heck of a war chest we've now
supported 190 000 troops on the borders
of ukraine this is where their policies
have led us
but right now senator hagerty given the
fact that russian troops have encircled
the capital of kiev
uh they're poised to bring in a lot more
troops if necessary
i mean what's biden gonna do about it i
mean this is this is where we are now
but
it's not like we're gonna be able to
push russia out of this situation as
long as china which you've been you've
been terrific on the china question as
long as china
is giving giving another cushion to
vladimir putin
absolutely and what we've done is
actually pushed russia closer to china
through these activities again putin has
seen the weakness that the biden
administration has demonstrated nowhere
worse than the fall of afghanistan when
so many other things begin to ratchet up
against us around the world china is
watching this very closely and again
china and russia have been
even closer to the process of this
engagement here i think if you look at
what the ccp must be thinking about this
they're eyeing taiwan very closely they
want to see what the world's reaction is
going to be to this and it's not working
out well for the rest of the world
certainly not working out well for
taiwan but our strategic interests are
much greater with respect to china if
you think about taiwan the semiconductor
industry there
we could be in much deeper trouble
strategically if china decides to take a
move based on what they see happening
here with ukraine
well hillary clinton uh spoke on msnbc
this morning senator
and
she's actually
praising the biden administration's
response here watch
i first want to ask you what you think
of president biden's response so far and
it has been
well
executed
there is no doubt that we were not in a
position just a few years ago to rally
anybody and then to begin imposing
sanctions that will ratchet up
and i think that is exactly what he
should be doing
i guess senator the litmus test tonight
is we didn't see any people falling out
of airplanes on the way out of the
ukrainian airfield that's kind of the
definition of success meanwhile we have
hundreds of thousands of people
underground in subways in ukraine and
lord knows how many people have already
lost their lives
it's amazing and they're taking credit
for the sanctions that they're imposing
now when they should have done the
sanctions months ago if not weeks ago i
was calling them to do that the biden
administration has been so feckless in
this finally they've come around to
imposing sanctions but a little bit too
late a little bit too late they had no
deterring effect at this point now
they're just going to punish and and not
to a very great extent
senator hagerty we appreciate your
joining us tonight hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else